Good question.
Ask yourself what would motivate you?
You know,
first of all,
don't be studying eight hours a day
cause that isn't going to work and you're
not going to do it anyways.
You know,
when you start studying
five minutes a day,
seriously,
would you,
could you bring it up to 10 minutes a day?
What would you have to do for yourself
to get yourself to sit down for half an
hour a day and,
and study intently?
Like maybe you'd have to,
I don't know what you'd have to do,
like have a beer at six
o'clock at night or something.
Or maybe you'd have to go for a walk
in the park or go out for coffee.
It's like,
imagine that you're sitting down with
a stupid undisciplined child who,
and you're trying to get that child
to do something useful and you say,
okay,
look,
I want you to do x.
It's necessary,
but you can pick how much of it you're
going to do and I'll give you what you
want if you do it well,
ask yourself that and see what happens.
So don't try to tyrannized yourself,
you know,
try to negotiate with yourself and use
some reward and see how that works and
start slow.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you're not very disciplined and
the best you can do is half an hour of
studying a day.
Well start with half an hour.
Increase that five minutes a week.
You know,
if you do that,
that's a lot.
If you,
if you do that for a year,
then you'll,
by the end of the year,
you'll be studying four hours a day.
So you can eat.
That's,
that's just with five,
that's just with five minutes a week,
right?
Because that's 250 minutes in a year.
So start ridiculously pathetically study
for five minutes a day for a week and
then move it to 10 you may have
to do that and don't cheat.
You know,
because one of the things people do is
they make a deal with themselves like
that.
I'm all,
I'm going to study for 10
minutes a day each day.
And then they,
they get into it,
they think,
wow,
this is going really good.
So they study for two hours and then
they broken the contract with themselves
and they don't trust themselves anymore.
And then they don't study
for a whole year or,
well,
maybe not for a month.
So,
but set your contract,
ask yourself,
you know,
what could I do to move myself
forward to my goal that I would do?
And then how can I improve
that incrementally?
So that's the right way
of going about that.
So,
okay.